All right, here's what I did. I first of all computed the reduction 0 to 5 that
you've seen just a few minutes ago and multiply that by 51 to get one of these
six values. That's the job for red. It's the exact same for green, and for
blue. Let's try it out. When I run the program, I can pick an image. I get to
see it before the change is applied. And when I click on OK, then the change is
applied. And when you look carefully, you'll now see that the image looks
coarser. It has fewer colors, for example, in this range here. Now fortunately,
my cat Eliza isn't on a distant planet. But if she was, then it would take far
fewer pixels to send her image to me. The exact equations that we just used
aren't really important to remember. But the point that I wanted to make is
that even though integer division doesn't sound like the most interesting thing
in the world. It can be put to good use and give you a fun application. Go
ahead and practice that a bit more with Sarah.